Bueno, normalmente en la medicina clínica tenemos
esta expectativa, digamos, bastante reconfortante de que el
diagnóstico va a ser algo binario.
Claro, o sea, te rompes un brazo, ves la radiografía y ya está.
Exacto. El médico señala la línea blanca en el hueso y te dice que ahí está
el problema. La imagen es clara, la decisión es súper directa.
Pero cuando cruzamos la frontera hacia la neurología clínica…
¡Uy! Ahí, esa máquina de rayos X conceptual se hace pedazos
totalmente.
Sí, se desmorona. Y más aún si entramos al territorio de las
enfermedades desmielinizantes, porque ahí nos encontramos frente a un panorama
diagnóstico donde el error, este, no es simplemente archivar un
expediente con el nombre equivocado.
Para nada. El error en este terreno tiene consecuencias orgánicas
y, la verdad, muy destructivas.
O sea, asumir automáticamente un diagnóstico solo porque ves una mancha blanca
en una imagen cerebral puede ser letal.
Y fíjate que esa es justamente la premisa central de nuestra inmersión clínica de
hoy.
Porque equivocarse al diferenciar entre una
esclerosis múltiple y el espectro de neuromielitis óptica es una trampa.
Una trampa enorme.
Recetar los fármacos modificadores de la esclerosis múltiple a un paciente
que en realidad tiene neuromielitis óptica no es que sea, digamos, un tratamiento
ineficaz. Es literalmente echarle gasolina a un incendio
neurológico.
Tal cual. Por eso, la mejor herramienta que tenemos, y a veces
la única herramienta real antes de que lleguen esos resultados de resonancias de
altísima resolución, es una semiología clínica implacable.
Totalmente de acuerdo.
La clínica siempre manda.
Y para desentrañar todo esto, hoy vamos a analizar un caso clínico socrático
que me pareció espectacular.
Proviene de la Cátedra de Neurología Clínica y Semiótica del Hospital Carlos
Andrade Marín, allá en la Universidad Central del Ecuador.
Es un caso fabuloso porque no se queda en la teoría abstracta.
Exacto. Nuestra misión hoy no es repasar la teoría básica de los
libros de texto.
O sea, quienes nos escuchan, los internistas, los residentes que
están ahí en la guardia a las 3 de la mañana, ya saben lo básico.
Claro, el objetivo aquí es aplicar un método estricto.
El método de conocer, razonar y actuar.
El famoso No Reason Act, para evitar caer en esa trampa
diagnóstica mortal.
Así que, vamos a empezar dibujando el escenario clínico.
Tenemos a una paciente, femenina, de 27 años, es
diseñadora gráfica, sin comorbilidades.
Su motivo de consulta cuando llega a la sala de urgencias es que
relata que desde hace cinco días siente las piernas dormidas.
Parestesias, o sea, un hormigueo ascendente, ¿no?
Sí, parestesias ascendentes desde el ombligo hacia abajo.
Y aquí viene un detalle clave del interrogatorio.
Al agachar la cabeza para mirar su teléfono, siente una descarga eléctrica,
como una corriente que le baja por toda la columna vertebral.
¡Guau! Eso para el examinador que sabe qué buscar en la médula cervical es
supervisual.
Estamos hablando de un nivel sensitivo incompleto en T10
y ese síntoma eléctrico tan clásico.
Y al indagar un poco más en la cronología, vemos que estos síntomas se instalaron
de forma subaguda, digamos en unas 48 horas, y han estado estables los
últimos tres días.
Ajá. Y además tiene urgencia miccional, que no es un dato menor.
Para nada. Ahora, los signos vitales revelan algo importantísimo en este punto.
La paciente no tiene fiebre, no hay disuria, no hay ningún otro
síntoma urinario irritativo crónico, y el cuadro no fue precedido
por ninguna infección aparente.
Ese contexto es vital para lo que viene.
Exacto. Entonces, aquí viene el primer desafío socrático del documento para los
clínicos que nos están escuchando.
Vamos a dejar un brevísimo silencio mental para que lo razonen.
Con estos datos crudos sobre la mesa, ¿cumple este evento neurológico la
definición operativa estricta de un brote?
Es la pregunta del millón en la guardia.
Sí. Hablemos del veredicto clínico.
O sea, ¿es o no es un brote?
La respuesta es sí. Y fíjate que no se trata de una impresión clínica
subjetiva del médico, sino de matemáticas fisiopatológicas.
A ver, explícanos esa matemática.
Claro. Para definir operativamente un brote desmielinizante,
necesitamos cumplir tres variables.
Y esta paciente las tiene todas.
Primero, la temporalidad del déficit, que debe durar más de
24 horas. Ella ya lleva cinco días con el déficit sensitivo.
Ajá, o sea, la primera casilla está marcada.
Exacto. Segundo, la cinética de instalación.
Fue subaguda a lo largo de un par de días.
Eso nos ayuda a descartar algo vascular, que sería de inicio
súbito en cuestión de segundos.
Claro, un infarto medular te tumba en el acto, no te avisa por dos días.
Tal cual. Y el tercer pilar, que la verdad suele ser la trampa más
grande en las salas de emergencia, es la ausencia total de un estado
proinflamatorio sistémico.
Ah, o sea que no haya una infección de fondo.
Exactamente. La paciente está febril y, lo más crucial,
tiene un EMO, un examen general de orina, completamente normal.
Bueno, y te digo que ese hemo normal va a ser el salvavidas de la guardia más
adelante. Ya vamos a llegar a eso.
Pero el caso da un giro interesante porque el interrogatorio dirigido viaja al
pasado.
Siempre hay que escarbar en el pasado neurológico.
Sí, porque la paciente recuerda que hace 14 meses tuvo visión borrosa
en el ojo derecho con un dolor profundo, especialmente al mover el globo ocular.
Dice que le duró unas tres semanas.
Un oftalmólogo le dijo que su fondo de ojo era normal y mejoró sin ningún
tratamiento.
El típico caso de neuritis óptica que pasa medio desapercibida o que se
resuelve sola.
Y el gran problema aquí es cómo un médico de guardia convierte hoy un relato
súper subjetivo de «me dolió el ojo hace un año» en un signo clínico objetivo
e innegable.
Ahí es donde entra la prueba de la linterna oscilante.
Es una maravilla semiológica.
Lo que buscamos es el defecto pupilar aferente relativo derecho, el
famosísimo signo de Marcus Gunn.
La fisiopatología detrás de eso me parece fascinante.
Es bellísima. Piensa en esto.
Si el nervio óptico derecho sufrió una neuritis retrovulvar hace
14 meses, perdió mielina y, por lo tanto, perdió una
cantidad significativa de acciones funcionales.
Es decir, el cable quedó pelado y con menos fibras.
Exacto. Entonces hoy, cuando pasamos la luz rápidamente del ojo
izquierdo sano al ojo derecho lesionado, el cerebro de repente recibe
una señal luminosa mucho más débil de ese lado derecho.
Y claro, el tronco encefálico se confunde, ¿no?
Sí, la respuesta refleja del tronco es disminuir la constricción pupilar
bilateral porque siente que hay menos luz.
Así que, paradójicamente, cuando le iluminas directamente el ojo
derecho lesionado, parece que ambas pupilas se dilatan.
Me encanta esa mecánica. Es como si el cerebro estuviera diciendo,
oye, no estoy recibiendo suficiente luz por este cable, abran las cortinas.
Incluso cuando le estás apuntando con una linterna directo a la pupila.
Es una analogía perfecta.
Y ese cable dañado deja más rastros.
Si la examinamos hoy, notamos desaturación del color rojo.
O sea, ve el rojo como si estuviera desteñido, ¿verdad?
Ajá. Un signo súper temprano de neuropatía óptica.
Y si además usamos el oftalmoscopio, ya no vamos a ver ese fondo
de ojo normal que le vieron hace 14 meses.
Me imagino que ya hay secuelas visibles.
Totalmente. Veremos palidez temporal del disco óptico derecho, que es la
secuela trófica de la capa de fibras nerviosas.
Así que, con una simple linterna y un oftalmoscopio, el
clínico acaba de demostrar que hubo diseminación en el tiempo.
¡Guau! Y eso cambia toda la forma en que abordamos a la paciente en la urgencia.
Pero fíjate que hay otro hallazgo en la anamnesis que parece casi anecdótico, pero
fisiopatológicamente es oro puro.
A ver, ¿qué más contó la paciente?
Dice que cuando se ducha con agua muy caliente, la visión de ese mismo ojo derecho
se le empaña. Empeora por unos minutos hasta que se enfría al salir del baño.
¡Ah! El detonante térmico.
Clásico.
Volviendo a la analogía de los cables, es como si un circuito que ya estaba
desgastado no soportara el sobrecalentamiento térmico y
el cuerpo decidiera bajar los breakers por seguridad.
¿Por qué ocurre este cortocircuito exactamente con el agua caliente?
Lo que describes clínicamente es el fenómeno de Uhthoff.
Y a nivel celular, lo que está pasando es un bloqueo de conducción
transitorio que es totalmente dependiente de la temperatura.
A ver, ¿cómo funciona eso en el axón?
Bueno, en un nervio sano, la mielina permite que el impulso
eléctrico salte rápidamente.
Cuando la mielina se destruye por la inflamación que tuvo hace 14
meses, el axón intenta compensar.
Lo que hace es redistribuir sus canales de sodio dependientes de
voltaje a lo largo de todo ese segmento que quedó desnudo.
Trata de adaptarse para seguir transmitiendo.
Sí, pero este nuevo equilibrio es extremadamente frágil.
Entonces, al elevarse la temperatura corporal central, ya sea por una
ducha caliente, ejercicio o fiebre, la cinética de estos
canales de sodio se altera.
O sea, se cierran o se abren mal.
Se cierran demasiado rápido, y esto impide que el potencial de acción se
propague. El nervio literalmente deja de transmitir electricidad por unos
minutos.
Y la regla cardinal para el clínico es que esto dura de minutos a horas
y revierte al enfriarse.
Por lo tanto, esto no es un brote activo.
Para nada, no es un brote.
Es una falla mecánica antigua que se manifiesta solo por el calor.
O sea, un pseudobrote.
Si el residente en la guardia no indaga sobre el detonante térmico,
podría ingresar a la paciente pensando que está teniendo una crisis óptica nueva.
Lo cual llevaría a intervenciones totalmente innecesarias.
Y fíjate que el examen neurológico completo de esta paciente revela otros
datos locales invaluables.
¿Qué más le encontraron?
Al evaluar los movimientos extraoculares, cuando intenta mirar hacia la
izquierda, el ojo derecho no aduce, es decir, no cruza la
línea media hacia la nariz.
¿Se queda rezagado?
Sí, y simultáneamente, el ojo izquierdo, el que está abduciendo hacia
afuera, presenta un nistagmo horizontal.
Básicamente, estamos viendo en vivo una oftalmoplejía internuclear
derecha.
Es decir, la orden del cerebro de mirar hacia un lado se fragmenta en el
camino.
Exacto. Y eso localiza la lesión con una precisión
nanométrica directamente en el tronco encefálico,
específicamente en el fascículo longitudinal medial derecho.
Claro, ese es el tracto que cruza la información, ¿no?
Así es. Es el puente que conecta el núcleo del nervio abducens de un lado con
el subnúcleo del motor ocular común del lado opuesto.
Al desmielinizar ese puente, la comunicación se rompe.
Y si sumamos eso al signo de Lhermitte del principio, esa
corriente eléctrica al flexionar el cuello, eso nos indica desmielinización en los
cordones posteriores de la médula cervical.
O sea, tenemos un mapa anatómico clarísimo.
Literal. La paciente además tiene reflejos osteotendinosos exaltados,
Babinski bilateral y el nivel sensitivo en T10, entonces mapeamos el
nervio óptico, el tronco encefálico y la médula espinal prácticamente usando solo
las manos y una linterna.
Que es la verdadera magia de la semiología.
Pero claro, sabemos que en la medicina actual ningún clínico se va a detener
ahí, ¿verdad?
El siguiente paso lógico y el protocolo es pedir las imágenes.
Y aquí es donde entran al juego los famosos criterios de McDonald
2017.
Sí, indispensables para formalizar el diagnóstico.
Cuando la resonancia magnética llega a nuestras manos,
¿cómo aplicamos realmente los conceptos de diseminación en espacio
y tiempo
Bueno, la diseminación en espacio, o DIS, no
es simplemente encontrar lesiones aleatorias
por ahí. Los criterios exigen afectación en al menos dos de
cuatro áreas muy específicas
del sistema nervioso central.
Porque la esclerosis múltiple tiene una predilección anatómica, no ataca al azar.
Exactamente. En nuestra paciente, el análisis radiológico
reporta un pleno total, o sea,
Hablemos un poco de por qué se ubican donde se ubican.
Tienen las clásicas lesiones periventriculares, esos famosos dedos de Dawson que
son perpendiculares al cuerpo calloso.
Y entiendo que no tienen esa forma solo por casualidad.
No, para nada. Su forma revela su origen patológico.
Los dedos de Dawson siguen el trayecto de las vénulas medulares
profundas.
O sea, siguen a los vasos sanguíneos.
Sí, porque la desmielinización en la esclerosis múltiple es un proceso
perivenular. Las células inmunitarias cruzan la barrera
hematoencefálica a través del endotelio de la vena y atacan la mielina
circundante. Por eso la inflamación se extiende de forma radial,
dibujando, digamos, la anatomía del vaso sanguíneo.
Eso explica perfectamente la forma perpendicular.
A esto se le suma una lesión yuxtacortical frontal, otra
infratentorial en el pedúnculo cerebeloso medio derecho, y bueno, la
lesión en la médula espinal. Eso confirma el espacio.
Bien, entonces tenemos el espacio cubierto.
Para la diseminación en tiempo, o DIT, la resonancia nos muestra
algo bien dinámico. Coexiste una lesión medular periférica, en un
segmento entre T8 y T9, que realza con el contraste de gadolinio.
O sea, es una lesión activa.
Sí, y está junto con las otras lesiones periventriculares que no realzan.
Básicamente, estamos viendo el registro histórico del daño.
Cicatrices viejas y apagadas conviviendo junto a un incendio nuevo
y activo.
Esa es la definición visual de la diseminación en el tiempo.
Y por si fuera poco, el estudio del líquido cefalorraquídeo arroja
bandas oligoclonales tipo II.
Que esa es la firma inmunológica intrínseca de la enfermedad.
El patrón tipo II significa que hay bandas oligoclonales
restringidas exclusivamente al líquido cefalorraquídeo, sin estar
presentes en el suero.
O sea, ¿la fábrica de anticuerpos está adentro del cerebro?
Exacto. Esto confirma la síntesis intratecal de
anticuerpos. Hay clonas de linfocitos B produciendo
inmunoglobulinas dentro del sistema nervioso central.
Y clínicamente, encontrar estas bandas puede incluso sustituir la
necesidad radiológica de diseminación en tiempo.
Claro, en casos donde la resonancia inicial tal vez solo te muestra
lesiones de la misma edad y no tienes esa dualidad activo-inactivo.
Exactamente, las bandas te salvan el diagnóstico temprano.
Ok, hasta aquí, la clínica y la imagen encajan perfectamente
en una esclerosis múltiple clásica.
Pero aquí viene la trampa diagnóstica de la que hablamos al principio.
Ese punto de giro donde el razonamiento automatizado mata.
Y este es el momento crucial de la discusión de hoy.
Sí. Quiero plantear un escenario alternativo radical para retar esto.
Imaginemos por un momento que la resonancia medular de esta paciente no muestre esa
pequeña lesión periférica en T8-T9.
A ver, ¿qué vemos entonces?
Imaginemos que muestra una lesión central, destructiva, continua, que
va desde la vértebra T3 hasta la T9.
Es decir, abarca más de tres segmentos vertebrales de largo.
Una mielitis longitudinalmente extensa.
Y supongamos que aquel episodio de visión borrosa hace 14 meses no
mejoró solo, sino que fue una pérdida de visión severa, catastrófica,
digamos de 20 sobre 200, y además bilateral.
Si el médico de guardia ve ese escáner, ¿qué cambia en su abordaje?
Cambia absolutamente todo.
Cambia el diagnóstico base y, sobre todo, cambia el pronóstico vital
de la paciente. Ese cuadro clínico que describes, mielitis
longitudinalmente extensa, de tres o más segmentos, más una neuritis
óptica severa bilateral, grita espectro de neuromielitis
óptica.
La famosa NMOSD.
Exacto. Y aunque visualmente en una resonancia de baja calidad
ambas te puedan parecer manchas blancas, la fisiopatología es
radicalmente distinta.
La esclerosis múltiple es una enfermedad desmielinizante primaria, pero
la neuromielitis óptica es, en su núcleo, una astrocitopatía
autoinmune.
Espera, me vas a perder un poco aquí.
Si en ambos casos el paciente termina desmielinizado y perdiendo
funciones neurológicas, la lógica del internista a las 3 de la mañana
dictaría que un inmunosupresor diseñado para esclerosis múltiple debería,
al menos, mitigar la neuromielitis óptica, ¿no?
Suena lógico, pero es letal.
Por eso, ¿por qué me dices que recetar los fármacos de la esclerosis múltiple en
este escenario contraintuitivo es un error catastrófico?
¿Qué está pasando ahí a nivel celular para que la cura empeore la enfermedad?
Para entender eso, tenemos que mirar al objetivo celular del ataque.
En la NMOSD, los autoanticuerpos no atacan la
mielina a la entrada. Atacan los canales de agua aquaporina-4.
Que están en otra célula, ¿verdad?
Exacto, están ubicados en los pies de los astrocitos que forman
parte de la barrera hematoencefálica.
Si a un paciente con NMOSD le recetas terapias
modificadoras para esclerosis múltiple, y aquí quiero ser súper específica,
específicamente interferón beta, natalizumab o
fingolimod, puedes desencadenar una recaída devastadora.
A ver, desglosemos eso.
Tomemos el fingolimod como ejemplo.
¿Qué hace exactamente y por qué falla?
Bueno, su función en la esclerosis múltiple es atrapar a los linfocitos T
en los ganglios linfáticos, para que no lleguen al cerebro.
Suena bien en teoría.
Sí, pero al alterar este delicado equilibrio inmunológico periférico,
paradójicamente, el fingolimod puede favorecer la expansión de
subpoblaciones de células B.
Y estas células B son las que producen agresivamente los
anticuerpos AQP4-IgG.
O sea, al intentar frenar a los linfocitos T que causan la esclerosis múltiple,
¿terminas dándole vía libre potenciando a los anticuerpos que están destruyendo los
astrocitos en la neuromielitis óptica?
Exactamente. Estás reconfigurando todo el sistema inmune a favor del
enemigo. El daño no se mitiga, se amplifica de forma brutal.
¡Guau! ¿Y con el natalizumab pasa algo parecido?
Con el natalizumab pasa algo similar, sí.
Al bloquear la integrina VLA-4 para que las células
inmunes no crucen al cerebro, alteras la regulación
sistémica. Y en pacientes con NMOSD, esto
resulta en necrosis espinal extensa y ceguera irreversible.
Todo esto es mediado por la cascada del complemento, que termina
destruyendo los astrocitos de forma masiva.
Es escalofriante. O sea, pensar que un error de clasificación
radiológica condene a un paciente a una discapacidad irreversible,
y peor aún, inducida por el mismo médico.
Es una iatrogenia severa.
Por eso, en cualquier escenario clínico que sea un poco atípico,
antes de etiquetar al paciente definitivamente de esclerosis múltiple,
el paso obligatorio, el que no se puede saltar por nada, es
solicitar los anticuerpos AQP4-IgG y MOG-IgG.
Los marcadores séricos.
Sí. Y ojo, tienen que ser solicitados mediante técnica de base
celular, que es la más sensible.
Definitivo. Y eso nos empuja al tercer acto de nuestra inmersión de hoy, la
acción en la sala de guardia, que es la parte más crítica de todo.
Volvamos a la paciente original de nuestro caso del HCAM, la que sí tiene una
esclerosis múltiple confirmada, con su pequeña lesión periférica en T8-T9 y sus
bandas oligoclonales en líquido cefalorraquídeo.
Ok, la paciente clásica.
Son las 3 de la mañana. La paciente tiene el nivel sensitivo Babinski bilateral
y está teniendo problemas bastante serios para orinar y caminar.
Tratamos agresivamente este brote en ese mismo instante.
¿Y con qué objetivo exacto?
Sí, la indicación clínica ahí es actuar de inmediato.
El protocolo para un brote agudo que es discapacitante y compromete la
marcha y la función esfinteriana sin duda lo es, consiste en pulsos de
metilprednisolona intravenosa.
¿A qué dosis estamos hablando?
A una dosis alta, un gramo al día, por tres a cinco días.
El objetivo fisiopatológico del corticoide en estas dosis masivas
es restaurar la permeabilidad de la barrera hematoencefálica, reducir
rápidamente el edema agudo alrededor de la placa desmielinizante y, bueno,
acelerar la apoptosis de esos linfocitos que están activos atacando.
Y aquí quiero introducir una aclaración que creo que es fundamental para el médico
general o el internista, porque existe este mito generalizado de que los
esteroides frenan el avance de la enfermedad a largo plazo.
Y es un mito muy peligroso.
Lo que realmente está pasando ahí es que solo estás apagando el fuego superficial.
La metilprednisolona acelera dramáticamente el tiempo de
recuperación del brote agudo. Es decir, la paciente va a volver a caminar normal
mucho más rápido.
Pero el incendio sigue por debajo.
Exacto. Los estudios clínicos han demostrado tajantemente
que los corticoides no cambian en absoluto la historia natural de la
esclerosis múltiple. No modifican el pronóstico a largo plazo, ni
evitan la acumulación progresiva de discapacidad.
Solo te compran tiempo en la fase aguda.
Tal cual. Para alterar el curso real de la enfermedad, el
paciente debe ser derivado a neurología al alta, para iniciar
verdaderas terapias modificadoras, no quedarse solo con el esteroide.
Arreglamos la crisis de hoy, pero la enfermedad sigue latiendo en el fondo.
Ahora, antes de firmar el alta de esta paciente, hay una instrucción, un
consejo súper contraintuitivo que el médico debe aplicar para futuras recaídas.
Es vital para cuando el paciente regrese a urgencias.
Sí, algo que rompe con el instinto natural de pedir una nueva resonancia magnética
ante el menor síntoma nuevo.
¡Ah! Esa es la regla de oro que salvaguardias y evita iatrogenias
en las salas de emergencia.
Ante cualquier paciente con diagnóstico previo de esclerosis múltiple que llega
reportando un empeoramiento súbito o el regreso de síntomas antiguos,
antes de pedir el contraste y agendar el resonador a las prisas, el médico
clínico debe solicitar un EMO, un examen físico y elemental de orina.
Volvemos al EMO del principio.
Suena, no sé, súper rudimentario para una enfermedad neurológica tan
compleja. ¿Por qué la orina dicta el manejo neurológico en este caso?
Porque las infecciones del tracto urinario son los desencadenantes sistémicos más
comunes. Una infección eleva las citoquinas proinflamatorias en el cuerpo,
como el TNF-alfa y las interleucinas, y eso produce fiebre o,
al menos, una leve febrícula.
Y la fiebre sube la temperatura central.
Exacto. ¿Recuerdas el fenómeno de Uhthoff que hablamos con la ducha
caliente?
Claro, el bloqueo de los canales de sodio.
Pues, esa elevación de la temperatura corporal inducida por la
infección bloquea la conducción en las placas de desmielinización
viejas que ya estaban compensadas.
Síntomas que el paciente tuvo hace años reaparecen bruscamente.
Es un pseudobrote.
Y el peligro gigante es que el clínico inexperto vea los síntomas neurológicos,
asuma automáticamente que es una recaída destructiva nueva, y vuelva a
prescribir un gramo diario de metilprednisolona.
Lo cual es un error médico garrafal clínico.
O sea, piénsalo, estás aplicando dosis masivas de inmunosupresores a un
paciente que en realidad está cursando con una infección bacteriana activa.
Le estás desarmando las defensas cuando más las necesita.
Es peligrosísimo.
Exacto. En el caso de un pseudobrote infeccioso,
el tratamiento no es el corticoide.
Es el antibiótico dirigido a la causa subyacente.
Los síntomas neurológicos van a desaparecer solos en el
momento en que se controle la infección y baje la temperatura central.
Es la encrucijada perfecta entre el conocimiento inmunológico profundo y la
semiología básica del día a día, ¿no?
Empezamos nuestra conversación buscando esa certeza clara y binaria de la
radiografía de un hueso roto. Pero descubrimos que en las enfermedades
desmielinizantes, la certeza solo surge de conectar el historial, el examen
físico minucioso y la comprensión real de por qué fallan los axones.
Y recordar siempre que el sistema nervioso central castiga
severamente los automatismos diagnósticos.
Cada decisión terapéutica aquí debe estar respaldada por un análisis
exhaustivo del espacio, el tiempo y esos desencadenantes
ocultos, como la temperatura.
El gran reto para la práctica clínica diaria es precisamente ese,
desconfiar de los propios reflejos automáticos.
Y bueno, quiero cerrar nuestra exploración de hoy con una provocación mirando
hacia el futuro. Porque estamos entrando a una era dominada por algoritmos de
inteligencia artificial, ¿verdad?
Claro, sistemas de radiómica entrenados para leer resonancias en
milisegundos.
Exacto. Vamos hacia un punto donde la máquina observará lesiones
en la sustancia blanca periventricular y automáticamente escupirá el
diagnóstico de esclerosis múltiple, sugeriendo el protocolo de fármacos.
Pero, si el algoritmo no puede sostener una linterna oscilante para
encontrar un defecto pupilar de hace 14 meses, ni puede interrogar sobre
una ducha caliente,
Ni contar meticulosamente si la lesión abarca tres o cuatro segmentos
espinales, estamos al borde de presenciar un aumento catastrófico de
iatrogenias destructivas en pacientes con neuromielitis óptica, todo
impulsado por una dependencia ciega a la tecnología radiológica.
Un pensamiento bastante inquietante para rumiar en la próxima guardia.
Hasta la próxima inmersión clínica.